チェーンソーマン見てるってあ今すごくバ
ズってるやついや
言っちゃ悪いけど
みんなが見てるんだったら俺はみんな見て
なくてもドラゴンボールみたいな伏線が
ないことが伝わってくるっていうか
ボルトより登場人物の成長が深いいやいや
いやいやいやだって主人公の名前がデンジ
なんだろう
マジで
腎臓マンの投稿が多すぎや元のストーリー
が良くても
CGは許せない
それは進撃の巨人のCGが良かったからな
んだよてか真っぱにはこのチェーンソー
マンを作る時間があればそれは巨人の最終
シーズンに使ってほしいいつまで待たせる
気いや第1話を見たよいや見たけどあの
OPは何マジでランダム過ぎこの声いやだ
からガーラ対きみまろのバトルを見た時の
俺の反応を配信してたんだよ見てそれだけ
楽しいってことだよ
チェーンなんて違って
痩せてが面白いのは認めるでもなるといい
ぞに好きになることは
スパイファミリーの話をしない
ダメだ
ガイ先生より姫の先輩の方が好き俺が
Twitterでバカにしていたあの
シーンも完全に伏線を張るためだったんだ
もう面目丸潰れた
ちょ待って俺って趣味悪いのいや今更前
アニメリストを演習したって何にも変わら
んバイバイバタフライを見てくるね
泣きたいからだよ
なぁなぁ見てる